who are joined now by the UK defense
secretary Ben Wallace uh Mr Wallace
thank you very much for being with us
this morning we've seen and Alex's
report there just indiscriminate bombing
of Civilian areas how is the war going
at this point stage day 13. well it's
not going particularly well for the
Russians it's day 13 way off the
timetable uh you know one level sadly
the sing you know there's a lot of
casualties we've seen the indiscriminate
shelling which is obviously killed
numerous civilians
we've also recognized that probably the
biggest single casualties so far in the
war Russian military soldiers who have
been let down by appalling leaders
Pauling leadership and appalling plans
and now you see them literally at large
scales dying and I think that is you
know something that will be interesting
in Kremlin whether they will admit to
each other the failure of the aggressive
and illegal invasion of Ukraine we've
seen the column is still stuck north of
Kiev there are reports overnight of
Ukrainian Special Forces destroying uh
you know over 20 Russian helicopters on
the ground and I think we can see that
the Russians are having real logistic
problems so that affects morale they're
not getting through they're getting more
desperate and you can see them getting
more desperate because they're shelling
more and more innocent people just you
know trying to even get out in
humanitarian corridors as we saw
yesterday and I think this goes right to
the heart of the challenge for Russia
which is Russia has built itself a trap
and it sent itself in the International
Community is knighted against them and
now we see the devastation that they're
leaving behind we'll come on to a lot of
that in a moment but you saw analysis
report there Petro poroshenko the former
president of Ukraine uh calling for more
Western support we're going to hear from
president zielinski later today who will
no doubt call for more Western support
are we doing all we can yeah we are
increasing our support of both lethal
and non-lethal Aid to Ukraine we're
continuing to deliver them throughout
the country we started off obviously
with 2 000 in-laws that's the light
Hunter tank weapons we've changed and
increased both the in-laws and others
and I'll make a statement tomorrow I
think to Parliament to give the details
but Britain is stepping up doing that
we're supporting the coordination of
delivery throughout Ukraine and you know
we were the first really to do this in
Europe and we did it obviously early in
January way before The Invasion and so
we're in a good place to make sure they
get better defense and more defense and
I'm in touch with my colleague in in
Ukraine quite a lot to get to know
what's going on and what they need I
mean there is some talk as well in the
past couple of days of reinforcing the
Ukrainian Air Force by swapping out Jets
essentially from NATO members Poland has
been mentioned with uh jets that the
Ukrainian Air Force can use your
thoughts on that and whether that's a
viable thing to do at this stage of the
war well first of all there's only
there's very few Nations that fly the
mid-29s which are the same aircraft that
the Ukrainian slice of the United
Kingdoms aircraft would not be able to
to be offered and so there are only a
few countries who potentially could
accept a request by the ukrainians I
would support the polls and whatever
choice they make it's those whether they
choose to whether they choose or not I
mean you know those countries are on the
borders with Russia and Ukraine to some
extent and so they will face a direct
consequence and so we would protect
Poland we'll help them with anything
they need but if they make that choice
then that's a choice they would have
made based on a view of bilaterally
helping Ukraine and Ukraine needing
those now I think Ukraine should have
whatever it can have to protect itself
to defend itself from this naked Russian
aggression to be clear then you would
support a NATO member essentially
rearming a bordering country against
Russia well I think I would support
their choice you know all of us in these
jobs have to balance the risk of
escalation with helping what we see on
the ground
I I am responsible for the security of
the United Kingdom and the people and so
as the Prime Minister and you know we
have to make sure uh that the
consequences of whatever actions we do
lethal Aid included which we know the
Russians have warned there'll be
retribution for for countries that have
done that is calibrated in the right way
to make sure that there's not an
escalation into a war across Europe
Poland borders you know a number of
countries such as Belarus that is an
active participant with Russia in this
war and Poland will understand that the
choices it make will not only directly
help Ukraine which I think is a good
thing but also may bring them into
direct line of fire from countries such
as Russia or Belarus and they will have
to calibrate that that's a really big
responsibility on the shoulders of the
president of Poland and indeed's defense
minister and so it's not for me to
second guess their choice but it is for
me as a fellow native member to say I
will stand by Poland Poland is our Al
has been an ally for over 150 years the
United Kingdom we will support Poland
whatever
Choice she makes and also whatever she
needs as a result of that okay Mr well
let's move on then to the migration
issue of courses you know millions of
people on move this is I want to show
you this picture here that we have
that's in a number of the newspapers
this morning and that we've been
featuring on Sky News that is the train
station at karaoke I mean you know what
that is reminiscent of don't you from
the 1940s
we can do more to help these people
can't be some 300 visas have been given
by the UK 10 000 wants to come here can
more be done and what do you think about
what you see there at karkiv look that's
what war in Europe looked like 70 or 80
years ago it's what war in Europe looked
like today and I think it's why people
like me and the Prime Minister
determined to help Ukraine defend itself
long before others were because that was
going to be the consequence we warned
many countries in Europe who were not
off the view Russia would invade that
the risk were great migrant flows are
what happens in war and you know we
we've got used to Wars a long way away
where people arrived on these Shores and
European Shores and drips and drabs as
they made it across uh territory these
people are neighboring the EU they're
neighboring Europe and quite rightly
they're in a city that is surrounded by
Russians who are indiscriminately
bombing them uh of course we can do more
and we are doing more and I think it's
shameful isn't it there's thousands then
300 visas have been given look they're
processing 17 000. so 17 000 people have
applied and they're being processed at
the moment and we've said we've said
over 200 000 people can come here so the
question really relies on how many
checks we do once people reach a safe
space so no one is stopping those people
getting across their borders into a safe
space and the first and foremost Duty
for all of us is to make sure those
people get to safety yeah once they've
got to safety making sure we just check
their identity before they come to this
country is incredibly important that we
do that it shouldn't take time and I've
offered you know and I will be offering
to the home office assistance from the
mod in the same way we did an operating
to increase the processing time to help
those people uh but but of course you
know we have been incredibly generous
and we will continue to be here we've
said over 200 000 people can come to
this country I mean 200 000 people can
come from Ukraine yes they can income
under the there's a range of schemes the
humanitarian scheme there's the family
scheme they can come to this United
Kingdom the key here and I understand
the frustration is the speed of
processing when they get to a safe
country and that's the problem is at the
speed of processing because you will
know that there have been stories in the
past 24 hours of people at the UK Border
in Calais unable to get across even
though they have every right to come
here why is that so I know the Home
Secretary is is determined to speed that
up and you know the mod will lean in as
we did so we're not pitting we we sent
mod officials to help the processing of
identity to make it even quicker we will
play our part in speeding that up you
know we have people in Poland for
example and the the ministry of Defense
as does the home office they've done a
pop-up Visa processing center but she
recognizes there's more to do you know
what's there at the moment is inadequate
you do admit that don't you look I've
said we can do more there and we will
lean in to do that you know this is fast
moving the first duty is for the
government to help people get to safety
and once they're in safe countries
Poland or anywhere else the next
responsibilities to make sure we process
them as quick as possible of course we
can do that quicker we are leaning into
the home sector is determined to do that
quicker I will give her all the support
I can in making sure it's done as
quickly quick as Lightning okay uh Mr
Wallace finally then uh president
zelenski is going to address uh MPS
today via video link he's been described
as a lion a real totem for this war what
kind of moment is that going to be like
in Parliament when he speaks to MPS I
think it's going to be incredibly
powerful you know um president zielinski
I've met on a number of occasions you
know he is leading a country at War I
don't think he ever thought when he was
elected as no one else really did or a
few people did that Russia was going to
come and decimate his country you know
he is an amazing guy he's a he's a he's
actually comes across as a very regular
person
um it's been an incredibly unifying
moment for Ukraine you know the last
president you've just seen on your uh
footage you know there's a joke in
Ukraine that you know Russia has done
one thing that the Ukrainian people
hadn't managed to which is unite the 4
former and the current president you
know that's what happens when you invade
a country president Jones gives the
spirit of Ukraine which is Young which
is liberal thinking which is outward
facing which is European and that's what
Russia or President Putin just doesn't
understand this is about values and who
we are this is not about the military
threat that was sort of made up by
manufactured by Russia to itself it's
about the values and President Putin
doesn't like the values that are
represented by NATO and the EU and
that's what he's most angry about okay